I think the locavore moment is brilliant
and it all makes perfect sense because
we went from kind of in the 50s and 60s
in America it was all about convenience
and anytime you cooked it was French
food and then in the 70s and 80s it was
this explosion of world cuisines and we
learned about Mexican and not just
Mexican but Oaxacan and food from
Veracruz and we learned about Italian
food and not just Italian food food but
food from emilia Romano and from Liguria
so there's been this evolution of
knowledge and sophistication and it's
all kind of come back down into where
the food from where you're from and even
the local or term has only been coined
two years ago in San Francisco it makes
a lot of sense I mean essentially what
it is is a food wilmuth movement that
says you should really your diet should
really be consisting of food that has
been harvested or processed from within
a hundred mile radius of your home and
that makes a lot of sense because you're
sustaining the farmers you are eating
food that is as nutrient rich as
possible you are contributing to the
greening of the planets by doing this
and you're helping small businesses grow
in your area so those are all very
important points and hopefully the food
is organic hopefully it's been harvested
or processed in a really healthy green
way you are really thinking globally and
acting locally I mean it really is kind
of the fruition of that concept which
was you know the in the last 10 years so
that you're really helping sustain your
area and the people that live within
your radius so to me it makes a lot of
sense and it's the way that we lived all
those years ago and it in terms of
health it makes the most sense for sure
because what it does is it forces you to
eat in a much more healthy manner